the ubu project is just it's it's
stunning and you know thank you David
you're you're you're a Survivor I mean
you you've hit rock bottom you know what
it's like you've been there so there's
no better person to sort of head this
Mission than you and I just think it's
wonderful why don't you just tell me a
little bit something about you know
about the project and what you're doing
well uh very quickly what and yes thank
you uh being uh a suicide attempt
Survivor thriving Survivor as I refer to
myself
is a very powerful thing uh March 31st
2009 I thought the world didn't need me
anymore and God and a bunch of doctors
thought otherwise and you know seven and
a half weeks on the psych ward blah blah
blah fast forward to 2016 or 17 JK is is
helping me put together a new CD of
Music I've been writing and I'm driving
across the Phoenix Valley and I hear uh
on the radio in an interview with the
statistic that the leading cause of
death for youth ages 10 to 14 in the
state of Arizona it was suicide unreal
and I was I was galvanized I thought
okay I'm I am a musician I'm a
songwriter I'm a teacher I've done all
these amazing things and more important
I'm a Survivor I'm recovering alcoholic
I got bullied you know blah blah blah
what does this all look like together
and so I thought about it for a while
kept recording the album JK sang on it
and then JK and I and my friend Walt who
was the road manager of REO Speedwagon I
don't believe in coincidence but we all
happen to be in LA
uh when JK was filming counterpart and
so we're hanging out in his trailer and
we're talking about this thing and he
and Walt went well of course you need to
do this and you know what are we going
to call it we came up with this name and
that name and the the phrase ubu had
been a part of my professional life
before and I thought about and I said
what do you think ubu project they went
yeah
and so what I did was was based on a
Model that our mutual mother used to do
a lot she was the head of uh artists in
the schools for the Montana Arts Council
and she would send you know theater
companies or a poet or a jazz musician
you know all of these you know top tier
people who just got tired of the Rat
Race and wow paid vacation in Montana
you bet
and I created this one week residency
model where I go in on a Monday I talk
to the kids depending on the school I'm
working with
sometimes I tell a little bit of my
story about the suicide survival and all
that stuff sometimes I don't it depends
on what the school wants to do and for a
week we have this ongoing conversation
about what hope and resilience and
self-compassion and empathy mean to the
kids I never defined it once for them
and at the end of the week the whole
time and this is all wrapped in the
guise if they think they're in a
songwriting uh Workshop which they are
but it's a parlor Trend because they've
chosen one of those four words I call
them Treasure Chest words they've chosen
one of those four words as the main
topic of their song
and by Friday they've written a song
sometimes it's just a chorus in a verse
maybe a couple of verses and a bridge
are thrown in there but two of my
favorite stories are there was a bunch
of fifth graders remainder these kids
are 10 years old
they're writing a song about Hope and I
use uh this makes me sound a lot more
educated than I am I use Shakespeare's
sonnet structure as my songwriting
structure because it's easy
um you know four sentences you know four
lines in any verse 10 syllables per line
there's a rhyme scheme the kids have a
framework to hang their creativity and
so I say okay right we're talking about
Hope and this and that what's a good you
know opening sentence what's a what's
the opening line of our song that is
just going to make the audience you know
oh my God I need to hear more and this
one girl raised her hand and I could see
by her face she had lived a lot more in
10 years than I had in 60. and she said
I hope that I get over my depression
and I said okay I understand that I live
with you know depression you know uh
post-traumatic stress disorder anxiety I
work with a therapist all the time are
you seeing someone yes congratulated I
was proud I said okay great now is it
your depression does it Define you or is
it just something you have to deal with
and she thought for a second and she
said no it doesn't Define me I said good
because your sentence is 11 syllables
long and we need to get rid of one
syllable what's one syllable that we can
get rid of and she said let's get rid of
my let's do
and so again room full of 10 year olds
came up with and of course it's an 80s
power ballad because that's the style
they chose for yeah
and they came up with I hope that I get
over depression because it makes me not
love myself yet that is definitely my
conclusion that's why I need some time
to have a rest
ten-year-olds are teaching me about life
balance in the chorus they came up with
shine as sort of the the go go-to thing
shine hope shines light on on depression
shine hope shines giving me compassion
shine hope takes away my obsession and
then I'm going okay we need one more one
more in this little kid like Horshack
and Welcome Back Cotter back in the 70s
oh Mr David Mr David Mr David what and
you know I could see the words coming
from his brain to out his mouth he goes
hope shines light on depression like a
diamond
no I do wow 40 Years of writing songs
never once have I come up with a mic
drop like that I'm surprised happens to
be on my new album that's coming out in
a couple of weeks I mean it's amazing
and you're pretty much saying that music
is Saving Lives absolutely that you know
so the ubu project augments a school's
existing curriculum with songwriting
music to help students address difficult
topics